Tito Ortiz just walked in yes sir what's
going on man how are you how are you man
doing good
enjoying this three-hour nap from New
York are you from LA to here you don't
seem affected like a lot of guys who
fight for a long time to have a little
you don't see what you've been affected
at all negatively yeah we were just
talking about like you've been able to
stay in fighter shape and even now when
you fight look not you know like you get
to a point where you watch fighters that
get older and you go that guy should not
be fighting anymore but you I've never
felt that when I watch you fight well
those are the guys because they're a
skittle different I brought I put on a
show but the same time always person the
dominant position on top I'm not there
to slug with the person until just
recently I guess Chuck Liddell I was
willing to slug with them and I put him
out in the first time how did that feel
because he had beaten you twice before
that and I mean there was a personal
thing between you guys are the same age
but I think right sorry he's at four
years older than me okay so you're in
the same age group but generationally
like you were the two kind of iconic
fighters and the two really first big
stars in UFC I think yeah I mean when I
first started my career back in 1997 I
was an amateur at the time I thought UFC
13 for free and I never had any fights
before I never came from a fighter
background I came from a wrestling
background in high school in college
collegiate wrestling and I thought I'd
just give it a try stop my first guy in
22 seconds so you see 1332 97 and I was
hooked how did it feel to finally beat
Chuck God let me tell you man it was a
weight off my shoulders and people said
oh he's an old man that uh he's the one
who called me out I was like Chuck you
don't want to do this I'm telling you
right now you don't want to do this and
he kept talking to something so he's
gonna knock me out if I turn down the
fight then I look like I was afraid of
the band I bet don't turn on the fight I
mean it's a lose-lose situation but when
I got my hand raised it was very very
gratifying let me tell you what you guys
have a history together sound like
you're you know yeah 25 year-old fighter
calling out somebody's in their 40s I
mean you know you guys you fought her it
look like that during the fight though
let me tell you yes I was on point it
was like he punched I was like slip snip
snip
I mean this is the first time I career
actually was slipping punches work with
Jason Perillo and it was just one of
those things that I
didn't want to get punched I didn't want
to get touched and so let's start moving
my head now before I would use my arms
my forearms to block the punches and my
game plan is completely changed and it's
gonna actually belong jod my career did
you carry those losses with yous are
those two losses like is that one of
those things that would weigh on you
like the Liddell Lawson yeah yeah well I
mean there was a lot of back story
behind that you know I'm with me and
Chuck Liddell being friends being the
first team punishment you know we
trained with each other for a long time
we had our own management and then Dana
became our manager there's a lot of
conflict of interest and ëifí his whole
Chuck you know any man if we're gonna
fight let's make a lot of money upon off
this I know we're gonna put our
friendship on the side and you know
fight each other let's make some
Millions
and he sold out you know our first time
we compete against each other he we both
made I think 150 grand
UFC made over 40 million dollars Wow the
second time we fought and we made decent
money we made about you know two million
apiece and they made seventy million
dollars I don't know I was pretty good
at math I was horrible at English but I
was pretty damn good at math put those
numbers together like that and I'm
making sixty percent to five percent of
the revenue of some put my life on the
line for it didn't make sense and Chuck
sold on our own friendship because of
money look at him now he's not he woke
up with the UFC and they fired and they
threw him to the wolves and he is
fending for himself and um I told him
exactly the truth what was gonna happen
truce in the future what happened it's
here now in front of us man Chuck don't
have a job
did you know immediately like what's
that fight started and you were kind of
seeing what Chuck was doing did you know
immediately like oh this is not the same
dude this is gonna be a lot easier than
I thought it was um not until the open
workout I we had the open workout and he
was hitting pads and I mean he looks it
like he still had the power but about
this he never was really super quick you
just throwing punches and awkward
positions from awkward angles and he'll
still throw in those but I was just work
with so many young guys at the time my
gosh younger guys I was sparring with
and it just it changed um I start
learning how to move my head finally
moving my head finally get another way
and stepping away and just getting the
distance right and you know I put in 18
we camp the longest camp ever put in my
career of 22 years I'm seeing with this
fight against Alberto Del Rio I've you
know I started about ten weeks
to go we have another eight more weeks
to go I just kind of realized that I
need to live into the fight world right
now and really focus on my career do you
get crazy when you're not fight as
though you just love to fight like you
probably don't need to if I don't want
to I hate fighting you do I love to
compete I'm very very very very very
competitive very competitive and
everything I do I mean literally walking
to the door I want to be the first one
no everything playing pool I mean gosh
fishing everything I want are you know
fun to play a board game with I promise
everything scramble everything I I'm not
even the rules it doesn't count what you
just did no that's not no word Tito Mike
and I look it up it is like yes so it's
one of those things what are you doing
you're not fighting it like when you
when you take some time off and you're
like all right now do I retire what do
you think of would you think of
retirement like for real
what do you think that you like 65 year
old band that is gray and broken down
and enjoying life with their family
that's unretired life I'm 40 year 44
years young I feel great I feel better
than I do when I was 34 no more injuries
nor just negative people around me you
know I've weeded out the the negative
people
that's what positive to be Pirani you
know I got a good girl a great woman a
Myrtle Cole Miller who's uh how'd you
meet actually we met back in UFC 33 she
was the first ring card girl through
through through Zuffa and a beautiful
model beautiful model mom but a
beautiful woman and beautifully to the
soul to the heart to the bone I mean
this this girl is not selfish at all she
is very caring I just I mean I can't
talking about her because she's such a
wonderful woman she stepped up as a
mother for my children and we've been
together now for six years and I'm very
very thankful to have her in my life she
saved me and she saved my family she
saved the future for me and like I say I
I live in a happy zone at home where
it's no problems you know I'm not
walking the eggshells at home I'm not
worried about just horrible stuff
happening in my house my kids are taken
care of you know there's not people in
and out of my home
it feels like a home when I walk into my
house and it's amazing is there a thing
with fighters and ring girl like like is
there like a like with the NFL is like
you know a lot of date cheerleaders do
they do they say anything to you like
look you're not allowed to date these
girls or they don't uh no not at all um
I mean I always it's kind of funny
because when we first met we described
we're on different opposite sides of a
relationship she was in a relationship I
was married and it was never never that
type of you know kind of course when she
walks about the green card like damn
that girl's fine
but I never went no further than that
ever but then when me and Jenna Jamison
broke up she actually came to my life
because I was going through some hard
times a time you know I had twin boys I
was taking care of and I was watching by
myself for almost eight months and it
was hard to take care of twin boys who
were four years old making sure that in
kindergarten I mean waking up for school
every morning and making sure they're
fed you know and I had a nanny who
helped me during my PI about four hours
out of his day but that just wasn't
enough it was just hard and I wanted to
make sure they had the right woman
around my kids for their future you know
um a little backstory for myself my
mother and father were had a heroin
problem and I lived through that from
the age of six to thirteen when I was
with jenna jameson she had a pill
problem and I didn't want that same life
for my kids future so I had to make a
sacrifice you know either is my future
um with her or it's gonna be the future
of my children and I had to make a stand
I had to make a statement and um I stood
my ground and I wasn't selfish anymore I
didn't think about myself anymore and I
thought about my kids future I don't
want to live how they live for the life
that I lived through as a kid and I put
my foot down and I said you know and
either you get sober or we're not gonna
be together anymore and she couldn't do
it and it's been six almost seven years
now that she's been gone she has been
around nothing tried to go through
courts because she couldn't do what the
courts asked her to do and she's been
gosh there's a Hawaii now she has a kid
and married and I know she just kind of
just left off face the earth she's
active on Twitter like she seems to have
been more conservative now which may be
you know some people find God and change
whatever it was it was wrong um some
people do I mean I I don't have no
contact with her at all like I say my
kids in my life and
if anybody who have children they
understand how much a love is for a
child you know and I did everything I
possibly could to make sure my kids have
a safe future and I did that and I'm
doing it and I don't know I'm did the
kids ever asked about her like you know
they don't they I mean she left when
they were four and a half years old four
years old yeah and so they don't really
don't remember they're always the
nannies and always taking care of them
you know I was paying twenty thousand
dollars a month and nannies moms Jenna
was sleeping until one o'clock in the
afternoon there was a lot of stuff that
happen that I found on court that is
just she should've went to prison for
the stuff she did and I just
was happy I walked when your parents are
like you're doing drugs when you're a
kid did they ever stop doing them and
they never get sober or they are they
alive or my mom got sober yes mom got
sober I was 13 she got remarried moved
me back to Huntington Beach I got a
second chance at life my father never
did he pretty much did did exactly what
Jenna did and it took me a while to
forgive him it was just last year or
actually just recently last year that I
went to see him for the first time in
almost 14 years and I kind of had to say
my piece you know I had to forgive him
because that's all he knew he didn't
know any better he was only kid wasn't
ever taught me better and I had to man
up and I know he wasn't so I had to man
up and I had to tell him you know what
Dad I understand how hard is to be a
parent I understand how hard it is to be
a father and I forgive you I love you
and I was the first time in almost 14
years I said I loved him and it meant a
lot to me and it helped just help
exorcise my demons was he apologetic or
was he really didn't get it I don't
think just because he's done drugs for
such a long time I mean yeah turn 80
years old I mean and he's been using
since he's been 30 Wow and he's just
fried yeah yeah to a certain point yes
um I mean he's coherent of course and he
just was like I walked in the door and
he was like wow he thought I thought you
forgot about me no no dad I just had to
kind of had to figure out what was going
on was what the problems you were going
through and I understand it I get it
um he's in he had a smile on his face
and you know I took one out to lunch and
we sat down we talked for a while and it
it just helped it helped help my heart
help me feel there's a reason behind all
these things there's a reason why the
things that I do there's a reason why
the things that makes me work so hard to
give my kids everything I never had as a
kid how old are you when you realize
that drugs are the problem with your
parents because it's six I don't think
you can fathom what heroin even is years
old and you know like oh this is why
this has been like this for so long I
was I was hiding there needles I was
hiding their needles hiding their drugs
and from them from the oh [ __ ] oh for
sure and I took an ass over one time
because
I guess I got a stash and I took it and
I threw it away and they asked me to ask
me to ask me and my dad finally beat me
down and I had to give it and it was it
was tough it was very tough um but it
made me the man I am today I mean people
say would you ever take that back not a
second I'm glad I went through that
because I was able to learn and I've
been able to help other people who have
gone through the same type of thing
knowing that you have a chance you have
a chance to change your life and the
chance to change your family um he's got
a responsible for your actions and
that's what I'm doing but you got it and
when you were younger to like you almost
went down that path right like you yeah
um you know I graduated from high school
and you know back in Huntington Beach
methyls a big thing and I I want to say
addicted but I was using with some
friends and it was just because of work
I mean I was doing 16-hour shifts in
those long days and I kind of lost
myself I went to a club with all my
buddies one night and I saw one of old
coaches and he's seen he's all Tito yeah
he was you doing all right dude yeah no
don't fight means you know look all
right
that night I went to went back home and
I looked in the mirror and didn't
recognize myself I was it's big you
don't even realize as it's happening
you don't I was six to 185 pounds I'm
six two and a half right now and I'm 235
so I mean there was a huge difference
pimples on my face big dark circles
under my eyes and he told me he was you
ever thought about coming back to school
oh yeah I did I just don't have any
parents take care of me I'm kind of on
my own he goes well we could pilot
possibly get you financial aid and that
Monday morning I walked into his office
he had a big smile on his face and he
says I think we could do this but myself
through school got my a degree I won the
state title twice in wrestling did you
stop using at that point just stopped
altogether stop that point I've looked
in the mirror and it scared the [ __ ] out
of me
are they testing you to in your
wrestling no no they're not drug testing
at all but like I say I I think this was
just a rock-bottom point when I looked
in the mirror and I was turned into my
dad and if I fear hit me I was like oh
my god this is I guess yeah and seeing
that through your parents like you saw
the reality of it as a kid so that you
it's not glamorized it's not anything so
once you see it starting to take effect
in you you know immediately I know what
this is I know exactly what it was and
it was just like say it was just a
breaking point of me and just realizing
and recognizing and going yeah I better
take care of the situation right now
before it gets something I can't handle
and then when you get married and you
find honor my wife is doing something I
was never married me and Jim were
married people always say that she was
my wife me and Jen are never married
cause I never trusted it but do you when
you wait he thought would you do that
are you like reliving childhood I'm like
trying to make somebody not do something
trying to control it like what yeah
there was that point I mean the first
time it happened was in 2012 that Ike
recognized that there was big problems
that came about you know cause she
always drank champagne you know did
sanics here and there and it wasn't
really serious but I mean half the kids
were born it kind of got a little
serious with painkillers she always said
she had migraines and so the doctor
actually gave her was a Demerol for the
migraines and I told the doctor my man
is this right my kids had come out okay
cuz yeah we're doing the low enough
doses there's me okay I'm not realizing
that it was
injectibles and she was doing over the
amount that he was asking and so it's
gonna ask I mean it did the dosage is
low enough but who's gonna sit there and
monitor to make sure that she's doing
the dosage right it wasn't she had her
assistant going on getting it all the
time and it was just I had no control of
it at all and I was going through a
fight camps at the time you know I was
fighting you have CEOs I mean I like top
of my game I was making big dollars I
mean I was always up in Big Bear
California training but that requires
complete focus on that yes yeah every
week I mean it would be Monday through
Friday through Saturday my hard training
camp Saturday night Sunday would be well
time off she would come up and it was
just we would always fight and when my
trainer he'd be like Tito man every time
she comes up here she breaks you down
and Monday we got to start all over
build you back up it was just like a
domino effect
I get built up and I get broken down
built up broken down then it was fight
time all the attention was on me and she
disliked that she hated it and she
wanted to get all the attentions just
she would do something extreme to get
the attention but before you would fight
before I would fight and it's one of
those things do you even see a pattern
at this point or you just like it's
happening but you don't even notice that
hey it's every time I fight I I saw that
pattern happen I think was in 2011 2012
mom and I recognized it and in 2011
before I fought Ryan Bader we slept in
the same home for seven weeks and never
had any conversations taking care of the
kids I would wake up at 8:00 the morning
actually 7:00 in the morning
eat him breakfast and get him ready for
school take him to school drop him
school I would come back and take a nap
wake up at 12:00 go to the gym until
3:00 come back at 3:00 pick him up from
school the nanny would come over a
couple hours I'd go back to the gym I
would train until 8 o'clock at night
come home cook him dinner put him to bed
and I would hop on my xbox and I'd play
Modern Warfare I could get away until
midnight and then every day
that's actly I was I never had a
conversation with her we slept in the
same bed for 8 weeks I'd go to the fire
for Ryan Bader and I'm walking down the
house she's like please talk to me
please talk to me and I was like listen
let me do this fight and I'll talk to
you I just had to get away from the
negativity and I did I won the fight got
my hand raised
Ryan Bader was undefeated at the time
he was a four-to-one favorite and I
stopped him in the first round and it
was just one of those things I got my
life straight and realized this is this
is this is my poison I need to get away
from it
yeah this is very very toxic
relationship and I did after that fight
was over there that went through another
fight I started talking to Amber at the
time and I just got to a point where
just I didn't want this in my life
anymore and I couldn't be selfish for
myself and think about myself I don't
think about my kids future and I did
that and how amazing is that when you
get into a new relationship right and
you cuz you come from when you're in a
toxic relationship you don't know he
talks of times like a million right
right I would never wish this upon my
worst enemy type of toxicity like
horrible but you don't know exactly how
bad it is until the very end like you
don't know what you've been living in
right and so like when you get into a
relationship that's healthy and you get
into arguments or whatever right it just
feels like nothing right it's it's crazy
cool it's funny cuz when I got close
friends my assistant actually was here
with me now Freddie
who's been my buddy God for since 2005
we know each other since kids um and he
told me like Tito man I'm telling you
this is this is not good for you am I
shut up dude I could fix this I could
fix this I was actually I was on Howard
Stern when we first hit together he's
like what the hell are you doing man oh
shut up Howard I know what I'm doing
I'll be able to fix it that's you being
competitive me being competitive man and
I grinded out and you know after we got
our separation when I have to have to go
to my therapy and I had to do a talk to
a therapist and I talked to him for a
good six months and come to realize like
Tito stop trying to save your mom and it
hit me in the heart it hit me so hard
I'll just like wow I get it oh yeah I
get it
and was it tough for you to go into
therapy somebody who's like so hyper
competitive and you know an athlete like
you to admit that there's something
wrong here there's a weakness and this
needs to be fixed by a professional um
not really I think I was looking for the
help yeah I was really really looking
for the help cuz you understand I mean
I'm very competitive
I'm not a fighter I'm gonna query's to a
tee I'm very loved you know I try to
help my friends around me I'm always
going out of my way to make sure my
people are in comfortable position so
I'm
when I got to that point it was just I
was looking for help
and when he was telling me the reasons I
mean excited psychology I was in college
so I understand their theories and the
ideas behind people's minds and things
to go through as a child and everything
so I was always wanted look for
questions of why I'm acting like this
why I'm responding like this and he gave
me those questions he gave me those
answers I was always looking for and it
was a lot of teared raking teardro a few
moments but same time you know I'm human
I've had billions and I'm much a big
brawl fighter it keeps people's asses
for a living now I'm a businessman who
saw a business opportunity and a very
competitive person and I've made
millions upon it and I'm thankful and I
look back now that I've been through the
coals I've been raked over the coals my
name's been raked over through the calls
how hard is that when it's public that's
the hard thing because there were so
many lies it just happened it was just I
had I had to own all of it I had to just
let the proof prevail you know the proof
the truth will always set you free and
it did it took a little bit of time it
hindered my name a lot of times when I
was with her and from being with her I
lost a lot of sponsorships and but
everything comes back full circle you
know I have an opportunity now making a
huge sponsorship that can't say yet
because we're in the midst of signing
the deal biggest sponsorship I read my
life and I'm very thankful for it but it
just shows that you know the hard work
pays off people see if the true person I
truly am and you know I live a very
transparent life a very open book
because of the things that go through I
want to make sure there's people in our
world to understand that when there's
hard times you can get through them as
I've been through them so anything worse
than when you're in a relationship
you're arguing about something whatever
it is and you're like you make your
point and then the person you're with
comes back with something that has
nothing and you're like who the [ __ ]
my mom am I in the same room right I
said to her this is why people don't get
married because this is like you hear
their [ __ ] in court and it's like I'm
with you and I could see this is how it
would be play that this is not at all
it's happening like you realize this is
a never-ending loop we're in right now
you're just trying to keep us fighting
we're not even talking about this in
exactly
yeah I mean and that's there's a lot of
situation I had was like that and it was
just her reflection her own self on to
me
you'd be distracted during camp
sometimes thinking about the fights or
whatever all of her using pills on my
house I mean the people having people
over my house transvestites over my
house I mean I uh and I'm not a racist
towards anyone at all but it's just
having my children around that
environment is not good and it was
affecting my kids I mean it was it was
really really gnarly um stuff I found
out in court I was just like going are
you kidding right now and I'm looking
the judge I'm like how will you let this
woman even stand here she'd be a to be
in handcuffs right now but they gave me
full custody I have full custody of
those children and they gave her a bunch
of things she need to follow through to
have a chance to see them and she never
followed there was one thing at all and
it's behind me now and so when a
therapist tells you stop trying to save
your mom yeah and that sinks in you go
holy [ __ ] are you able to let that part
of you go yes you are yeah was it helped
helped a lot yeah I kind of just it was
like a smack in the face was like
Freddie telling me Tito the man you're
in a bad place you're not you didn't
write this and I did and it was like all
this was like boom I seen those like
okay I didn't get my stuff straight and
I did and I have and it's great I mean I
get understanding at that point in 2012
when I left her out and I left UFC I had
I had everything of all these drums as a
kid and a Rolls Royce Phantom I lived on
the water on Eaton Harbor
I had a 38-foot fountain boat with 23
hunts behind my house on its own dock on
my own dock I had a Panamera Porsche
I had another home that my mother I gave
her for Christmas I had everything as a
kid that I've always wanted cuz I dreamt
about these things and yes it's just
material things but as a kid who had
nothing at all and came from nothing and
was able to work my butt off to make
that happen it was I was living in
Paradise I was living that white picket
fences I want with a family with kids
and I had a chance to lose in it and I
didn't want to lose it
and I told Jenna we're gonna lose
everything you can't this happen and she
didn't care she didn't care it I mean
she had eight million dollars and she
blew through in five years
Wow million in five years and I was just
and I kept on I'm well I'm she'd gotten
thirty thousand dollars so I'm shopping
sprees and you go you're not what are
you doing how many money she'll shut up
tell me to stop telling me how to spend
my money and I'm thinking about the
future my kids are going to school going
to college yeah
taking care of them and I've always
thought like that I've always put money
away and yeah when did you become a
business person like when when did you
see cuz you start in the UFC you're
fighting for free this is like a brand
new thing at this point no people aren't
making millions of dollars fighting in
the UFC
so what point did you start using your
your business brain um I think I had it
as a kid though cuz I mean when I was
younger and I say get away from my
parents I'd go fish on Newport Peter and
I'd sell bonito which is a type of a
tuna and I would sell it to the people
that for two bucks a fish and I'd get
their phone number down and I'd call him
sue the fish would try running and
they'd come up and buy all the fish me
so I had the little hustle of selling
comes like a mailing list with your
phone just call him he'll literally I
would go the big ball and I put in the
two dimes and make the phone call but I
had that hustle and when I started my
clothing company punishment athletics in
1999 which is my clothing cup and I
still have a punishment calm I would go
out in the each and every event I would
sell shirts myself and I'd make a 20
shirt $20 a shirt and I would kill it
you know I'd do 3 grand every show until
a day and all of a sudden said you can't
do that anymore I was like all right I
won't when you start paying us a little
more money and then I was the back up a
little bit when Dan was my manager what
was it Bob Meyerowitz who was the owner
UFC Dana was on him with the phone and I
was a champion at the time and this
before the patinas bought the company
and Dana told bone marrow is Tito Ortiz
deserves this amount of money if not
we're walking and hung the phone and we
were looking at Dana going man are you
sure you sure you don't doing the right
thing
he's all I don't know we'll see
him let alone an hour and a half later
Myra's calls back and says okay we got a
deal
Wow when I was making at that time it
was fifty and fifty thousand for the
fight and I mean I was the champ and I
thought that was great money and then as
the he became president he put me down
underneath one of his friends who was an
attorney as my manager mm-hmm there's a
huge conflict of interest in there and I
always said was like alright these guys
are starting to make money now once you
start asking a little more money they're
like nah man you don't ruffle their
feathers I'm like what do you mean get
their feathers you watched how this
worked yeah yeah just and that's when
the business since started coming I was
like alright this is not for our best
interest when on my own did my own thing
what's the most money that you made for
a single fight I'd got to say by about
3.2 million a bill well the after the
second Adelphi yeah I mean like I said
they made 70 million on that fight do
you think that you and uh like do you do
you and Dan have any relationship now or
is that one of those well there's this
thirty thirty four thirty that's coming
out October 15th I'm actually go to the
premiere on this coming Thursday and I
thought they're gonna be able to put the
line right down the middle rows neutral
mm-hmm and then I guess there was 19
edits that Dana had to go over and redo
it and redo it and redo it so now it's
like
10 to 90% to Dana and Chuck and knowing
10% for me and once again it's like I
deny the bad blood video that's coming
out have you seen the final cut I
haven't seen the final cut I seen the
first cut they did and it was even worse
than the final cut I hope probably her
and I I mean I literally I had to warn
them I was like um you guys can be
getting a cease-and-desist here you guys
put that out like that because that is
just complete assassination of my
character you guys cannot do that there
were so many lies and so many things
that just made me look bad and I was
just like you guys can't do that and
they were bummed they're like I mean
Dana had complete control over it and I
was just like how can a guy had control
of you guys I mean how do you lose some
you lose an integrity of the film you
lose in ourselves
did you know Dana was gonna have control
when you agreed to do it not one I
agreed to do it yeah I found it out
after I gotta do it if I would've known
he had control the whole time I would
never done it yes now it's just a UFC
project it's not a UFC project yeah I
would have never done it I would never
done it at all well it's supposed to
happen was Chuck told the truth said how
they fired him he was supposed to have
this contract for the rest his life or
he's gonna get paid that he got fired
and all of a sudden he has to pay for
his own surgeries he has to pay for his
own stuff and they're not helping them
at all um how were we getting paid as
fighters how we're supposed to come
together as fighters is for a union and
how UFC's not paying the fighters the
right way and all that stuff got cut out
there's so much stuff that I got cut out
and is there anything you look at to
Tito and you look back at the whole
thing with Daniel with Chuck or any of
that stuff well you look at you go I
could will you look at your own thinking
man I should have done this better like
is there anything you look at like where
you definitely screwed up and said you
know what this I should have done a lot
I should've been better at yeah god
they're Amish how long we have the very
very first thing is the gloves they had
MMA gloves the Hawaa know was actually
became a UFC glove I gave the first
prototype prototype of the glove to Dana
and I said this is the glove you guys
need to make the fire for us to fight it
they made it all of a sudden a company
called quano came up out and I got
thrown out the door I was like what the
hell just happened right now and I could
do nothing about it and all you know
they made the glove upon me am I on my
name or what I thought it was like
William H Macy and
Fargo going well no it's my deal the guy
it's my glove I know I mean stuff like
not mistakes like that business stuff no
were you at fault like like in
relationship that fault
like at lien relationships my
relationships have all collapsed a lot
of times I'm not at fault but I also
cheated like I was also shitty like in
there's been times robbers your shitty
so I'm saying is there anything that you
did that you're like [ __ ] I was really
shitty when I did it um with Dana Amy or
any of them yeah I was just one you know
I think wearing a t-shirt that says
Dana's my [ __ ] I think that was
probably the worst thing I've ever done
it's bad relations with the moss problem
I don't think there's any other person
and they work for a company that would
bore a shirt like that I probably should
not have done that but at the time I was
and I was in a bad place you know I was
listening to the wrong people
but everything else now I stood my
ground I mean I have integrity for
myself
at the night you know they're in a big
hoorah bunch of people around me I don't
have a big squad that rolls with me I
have 1 2 people with me and that's how
I've always been I'm very low pro I'm
down to earth I know I treat people the
way I want to be treated but at the end
the day when I look in the mirror and
brush my teeth about myself and I gotta
have integrity and respect for myself
and I've done this through my career and
you're fighting to we're gonna promote
while you're here yeah yeah is you are
fighting alberto el patron as they say
his name a patron trying help but the
wrong okay it's wrong and he's he was a
WWE guy but he fought MMA first
yeah he's as a record actually about
nine and five he's fought in Pride I
know he's fought in Japan a bunch of
times
former greco-roman all of us are not
Alypius medalist he got some background
I watched him a strange training stuff
and
thank you come back the American I
appreciate it I gotta say thanks Alberto
for actually have enough balls to step
up and I my wishes you know because I
get my standing ovation this guy has
some courage you know this guy's this
guy's a lion I got to give him the
respect and I've given the respect
because I started my camp like I said
ten weeks ago I mean I've been putting
in the work I'm not out you know having
fun doing the hoopla you're training I'm
training my butt off man this is this is
my life this is what I do and this is
what I love what do you think the
chances are that you will not win this
fight
there's always a chance I'm not gonna be
like there's no chance in my mind
there's no chance in his mind they think
he has a chance I don't think he has a
chance mm-hmm I don't I don't view any
loss at all
I don't be him touching me I'm gonna
punch him in his face so I'm gonna smash
him I just that's the way I trained
that's the way I am that's my mindset
you know I'm like an animal and I step
in the cage
I saw I've always been I mean I put my
heart and soul in the gym I'm putting in
you know anywhere from six to eight hour
days six days a week this is my life my
name my legacy this is what I live for
for almost 22 years now and I'm still
doing it the surgeries I've had athletes
don't compete and I'm still competing
and it's not even the factor of
competing it's another man is I'm
training and I'm doing the things that
I've done so I've been 22 years old I'm
44 now and I'm there I'm on point
everything's great tickets are on sale
Friday by the way October the 11th 10:00
a.m. at ticketmaster.com if you want to
if you want to go and obviously will be
a pay-per-view event on Saturday
December the 7th its from the the pain
arena at the us-mexico border and her
dogs on the border so this is one of
those things that Alberto Del Rio don't
believe in borders I am totally on the
opposite side I'm Pro Trump on you know
100 percent is it for tax reasons or for
immigration or both it's for immigration
it's for safety of our country it's for
the protection or for our military
finally someone's out looking for the
people of our country and I believe in
Donald I work for Donald Trump back in
2005 on the sly bear apprentice he's an
honest man he's a great man he's a very
smart businessman he's not a politician
and I think that's why people don't like
him because he's not a politician he's
looking for our country and this country
needs a business savvy person he is that
man and so you're working he'll for this
fight that is that's what is called
being an American as a heel notch and
I'm not to me well I guess all the
people in Hollywood were just too afraid
to speak up uh-huh I love I have to be
the hill and to support our president
then I'll be the
it is funny - I'm an American at the end
the day when I go to bed
I want my kids to have safety in this
country and that's what's number one to
me it is funny how if you wear a manga
hat or if you say anything supportive
about the president yeah like I said
it's never been like that in history
where like if you if you support the
bush people like is a Republican but if
you support Trump people somehow act
like you're this you're a criminal or
like how that like they just can't get
over the bank vault yeah yeah it's a
really crazy perception I don't get it
you know it seems like people they want
to help everybody else but the country
and I watched the debate the democratic
debate and they were talking about other
countries and other people and how we
need to take care of them it's like what
about us here in America
I mean how many veterans are homeless or
have health issues and mental health
issues how many people have mental
health issues who are Americans why
don't we take care of our people first
that's what should be number one and
Trump is doing that Trump is trying to
do that but he just keeps getting
sideswiped by so many different stupid
things are just fabricated fake news you
think the press is fair to him um no no
you see only here's another thing - so
I'm not a person who sits there and goes
oh I'm just gonna watch Fox News all the
time no I watch CNN I watch all these
other media outlets and it is just it is
propaganda I watched and just like how
can you guys see those things I just I'm
I'm baffled by it I mean are people that
uneducated to really understand that I
mean I believe on facts I want to see
facts I want to see him black and white
I want to see the proof of things not
with someone said of hearsay that's BS
that's mean that's high school [ __ ] I
mean why do that let's go about what the
facts are what's the proof isn't what
he's doing for our economy
that's important what he's doing for our
people that's important and finally as
the president's not selling our country
out to the highest bidder
I'm thankful for that so when you had
kids I used to change the way you look
at everything right because like
politics it's never ball to first I
never even cared about I never even
cared I mean yeah I still pay fifty-five
percent of my taxes to the country you
know I'm I I mean I I paid a big lump
sum over my 20-year career 20 year
career where I look is like where am i
money going all of a sudden they're
right and you know it's like was it four
billion dollars to Iran or
something like that I mean just these
numbers that were just over and I was
just an Offerman I'm like okay I'm gonna
start paying attention to this stuff and
seeing what it is really happening
where's all my money go yeah yeah for
the first time in my life I actually
voted I voted for Donald Trump that was
the first time you never voted that
first time I've ever voted how did it
feel going in for the first I mean I've
only heard it twice a song oh yeah yeah
I mean how does it feel going in for the
feeling anything made me feel proud it
made me feel like I was standing for our
country you know I'm a huge support of
the troops I've been to Iraq six times
I've been to Walter Reed Bethesda about
seven I probably visit overt gosh 30
bases across the United States Japan
Germany Iraq Iran from the quake border
all the way to the Turkish border I
finished I mean I each time I've done I
visit about 19 fob so I'm a huge
supporter of our troops and I just watch
the things they go through it and
hopefully Trump will bring them out when
you go to the bases to overseas you just
kind of just hang out it's like meet and
greets and you didn't just talk to
people and you know yeah he I mean no
god I have huge turnouts when I go
because I guess they get to watch it on
was it FS N or FNS the yeah the network
sources Network yeah course network and
they all watch my fights and they see me
come walking out with the American flag
and you know it's it's pretty cool it's
just the exception are the acceptance I
get from the fans are from the troops
it's just amazing you know they're 2,500
people of troops like waiting in line
you can get an autograph and talk with
me and they're so happy you showed up
they're like they're just happy that
you're there they're always the best is
like what I'm able to sit down with the
whole squad of guys you know there's you
know two or three hundred guys and girls
and I'm able to have a conversation with
I'm talking about teamwork you know
talking about our battle and what it's
like back at home right now how do they
feel and for that 30 minutes or that
hour I'm with them they feel like
they're at home they don't realize
they're in the sandbox and they're just
like I mean I talked to some of the
Colonel's they pull me aside I Tito
thank you for coming that was amazing
these guys and girls they they love it
man they want to feel like to be home
and can i boost him around a little bit
I think that's really important and I
think a lot of that is lost where they
come back home they kind of feel like
there's not nothing
to really be a sector - they fought for
nothing they feel like and seeing people
burning flags and stomping on flags and
I mean it's just pretty sad right now
it's a country that I think needs to
come together and you know this fight
against Alberto Del Rio you know him
being from Mexico and now he's an
American citizen me being an American
citizen born and raised in California um
I think we're battle over some a little
bigger than just a fight you know I
think we're battling for the future of
our country I think well you really look
well I mean and you sound great like you
literally one of the most unaffected by
fighting fighters I've ever talked to
like yeah yeah I've talked to a lot of
fighters and I mean lot of them sound
great but you sound exactly the same as
you did ten years ago which is really I
feel the same I did ten years actually I
felt better I did ten years ago
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM f
[Music]